this episode is brought to you by mac
weldon
mac weldon is reinventing men's basics
they believe in smart design premium
fabrics and
simple shopping i've been smashing and
testing
the hell out of a bunch of their stuff
and i'm gonna focus on their underwear
as one example
i've been wearing their air knit x five
inch boxer briefs
for a while now and i absolutely love
them i've used them to hike
in national parks like big bend i use
them to record podcasts
they can be used for anything they're
engineered to keep you dry cool and
comfortable
to the end of your workout or work day
the fabric is soft
lightweight microfiber which maximizes
airflow and stretches in every direction
it's breathable
moisture wicking and odor fighting which
is great for a bridge troll
like me here's what a few critics have
to say new york times slash wire cutter
evaluated mac weldon's 18 hour jersey
boxer brief
here we go quote our testers seemed
almost conflicted about how fancy they
felt while wearing these boxer briefs
quote these are lovely you put them on
and you feel rich one tester said
this underwear makes me want to waste
money on a hotel room and fancy boots to
seduce my already wife and spoil her
right added another
now to esquire quote an expertly
executed pair of briefs from a brand
that doesn't better than almost anyone
else
end quote now to men's health mac weldon
took the process seriously
with over 10 000 hours to perfect the
best underwear money can buy seriously
this one checks all the boxes you should
be looking for when purchasing underwear
end quote now back to me mac weldon also
covers a lot more
than underwear they have socks shirts
underwear hoodies
polos active shorts they check all the
boxes mack welding promises comfort and
a consistent fit for all of your basics
so check them out and try them out if
you don't like your first pair of
underwear you can actually keep them
and they will still refund you no
questions asked so you have nothing to
lose
again my favorite so far is probably the
air knit x
5 inch boxer briefs it seems like the 18
hour
jersey boxer brief is one of the most
popular so check them out
to get 20 percent off of your first
order visit mackweldon.com
tim tim and enter promo code timtim
that's
m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n.com
tim tim and use promo code tim tim
mack weldon reinventing men's basics
this episode is brought to you by aura
o-u-r-a it is the only
wearable that i wear on a daily basis
aura is the company
behind the smart ring that delivers
personalized sleep and health insights
to help you optimize
just about everything and i've tried
every device out there that you can
imagine
this one really makes the cut i've been
using it religiously for at least six
months now
and i was introduced to it by dr peter
etia who's also vetted
just about everything with advanced
sensors aurapec's state of the art heart
rate heart rate variability hrv
super important to me temperature
activity and sleep monitoring technology
into a convenient
non-invasive ring it's tiny it weighs
less than six grams and focuses on
three key insights sleep readiness and
activity so
i can use it to help focus my attention
on the type
volume intensity of exercise that i
should do in a given day
i use it to determine how certain types
of alcohol at different times of the day
affect
my sleep which they do and i can see all
of that in graph form trended over time
there are tons of actionable insights
that have come from using this ring
for me they have a number of incredible
people on
their team dr matthew walker a professor
of neuroscience and psychology at uc
berkeley
and also author of why we sleep the mega
hit
is ora's chief science advisor as just
one example
the aura ring is one of the most
accurate wearables available because it
measures your vitals directly from your
finger
so it's not deducing that or
making a best guesstimate based on a
bunch of other things and trying to
triangulate
compared to a medical grade
electrocardiogram the aura ring is 99.9
accurate for resting heart rate and 98.4
accurate for heart rate variability and
i work with hrv doctors and they
recommend
that i use the aura ring so try it
yourself it is
super cool and super practical very
actionable
the aura ring comes in two styles and
three colors
silver black and matte black i use matte
black
for 299 dollars you can give or get
the gift of health by visiting
auraring.com
that's o-u-r-a-r-i-n-g
com again that's
at this auraring.com i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal and personality
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of
the tim ferriss show i'm very excited
about this episode i'm gonna keep
my preamble short my guest today is a
repeat guest
one of my favorite guests sebastian
younger
on twitter at sebastian junior that's
j-u-n-g-e-r
he is the new york times bestselling
author of tribe war
a death in belmont fire and the perfect
storm
as well as co-director of the
documentary film restrepo which was
nominated for an academy award
he is also the winner of a peabody award
and the national magazine award for
reporting he's based in new york city
and cape cod his newest book
is titled freedom i would give a few
fingers to be
as concise as dense as powerful as he is
as a writer
it clocks in at minus the source matter
at the back 133 pages
so it is it is a fast read and a
powerful read for more sebastian you can
find
our first conversation from 2016. it
feels like a thousand years ago
at tim dot blog forward sebastian you
can find him online sebastian junior.com
at sebastian younger
on twitter facebook also sebastian
junior and then instagram
sebastian junior official sebastian
welcome
back to the show thank you tim it's a
pleasure to be back
a lot has happened since you were last
on this show and i cheated as i did last
time
by having a number of exchanges with our
mutual friend
josh waitzkin who is responsible for us
first meeting
i thought i would start with a question
that i really have very little context
on but
it is about a near-death
experience that you had not too long ago
and we kept this for this conversation
meaning i didn't
ask you to get into any of the details
before we clicked record but could you
please share your experience
yeah of course it was a profound event
and i'm still i'm changed by it and
still
navigating the new reality that includes
a
quite an awareness of being mortal i
never really understood it before i
realized i spent a lot of my life as a
war reporter and i've been in situations
that could have killed me
but i never expected that to happen at
home i always went somewhere else for
for my danger if you will and i was in
the middle of writing my book freedom
i'm an athlete i'm very healthy it never
crossed my mind i would ever be in
danger on a june afternoon in my own
home and i suddenly felt
this bizarre pain in my abdomen my
abdomen was suddenly flooded with pain
not unbearable pain
but way more than indigestion and i
thought oh my god that's odd what is
that and i stood up and i almost fell
over
i didn't know it but my blood pressure
was plummeting i had an undiagnosed
aneurysm
in my pancreatic artery it's pretty rare
it was a congenital
defect in one ligament that was pressing
down on my celiac artery and it created
a blockage it was an aneurysm that's
developed over decades apparently and
just one beautiful june afternoon on
cape cod
the artery ruptured and i started
bleeding out
into my own abdomen took them an hour
and a half to get me to the hospital
i started to go blind a lot of other
unpleasant things happened to my body i
didn't know i was dying
but by the time they got me to the
hospital i'd lost 90 percent of my blood
i was still conscious i was very
confused
the doctor asked if he could cut my neck
open to put a line into my
one of the big arteries in your neck i
don't know exactly which one but they if
they need to give you a lot of blood
fast
uh they can't do it through your arm and
i remember being puzzled and i said you
mean in case there's an emergency and he
said this is the emergency right now
god so yeah i said i said yeah do it and
then that was when i really started
dying like right after i gave the okay
my body started to fail i could feel it
i survived but
when i woke up in the icu the next
morning i mean all the nurses were like
no one can believe you're alive you
shouldn't like that was a miracle
and it particularly because i'm a dad
now a new father
that experience completely changed
my experience of almost everything what
was it like
in the days following that for you
and that could be physically emotionally
psychologically
anything did it take a while for it to
set in or was the
sort of reset or shock of that
experience immediate
you know in the moment i didn't know i
was dying i'm an atheist
i don't believe in anything right i mean
anything that you can't measure
or observe and as was my father he was a
physicist
but as i felt myself getting pulled into
this sort of dark
pit underneath me it's what it felt like
there's no tunnel of light you know
whatever i mean the things you hear
it's dark and it looks scary and i was
getting pulled into it
and right at that moment you know
they're working on my neck
and they eventually put 10 units of
blood into me and that saved me but
right at that moment my dead father
popped up and started talking to me and
consoling me comforting me
it was a long night i mean they didn't
really have me
safe until about 3 or 4 a.m they finally
found the leak
and plugged it with an embolism but that
took a long time and it was touch and go
for a long time but anyway the next
morning
i woke up in the icu i threw up a lot of
blood and
the nurse came in and said you almost
died last night like you're incredibly
lucky man and i that was a shock i had
no idea but
suddenly i remembered my dad and
some other things and i and all of a
sudden it started to
sort of make sense and i was profoundly
traumatized by it it was the safety of
the circumstances i was in my own
driveway
and the the fact that that you could be
struck down in your own driveway when
you least
expect that like bullets are nothing
compared to that fear so afterwards i
got out of the icu after a few days and
you know i just
my sense of the order of the universe
was completely rearranged
and i realized you know really nothing
is for sure i mean i
you know i know you can get cancer and
you can have a car accident all that
stuff we all know that i didn't know
nothing was for sure moment by moment
that was news to me and it gave me this
crazy sort of existential
either either an existential crisis or
an existential blessing
which is if you can be annihilated at
any moment
then it's each moment that's precious
and if you don't experience each moment
if you don't understand how precious
each moment is
you are missing out because that's all
you can ever be sure of getting is
what's happening right now
and it put me in this sort of weird zen
way and
i don't practice zen either i mean i
practice nothing except i guess
athletics um
it suddenly put me in this place of sort
of
zen grace i think of just being amazed
at the fact that any of us exist
and that we have children who we can hug
and love
you know like at the end of the day like
those two things amazed me
so profoundly that it was almost hard to
function for a while
that's terrifying and for those who
don't have
a bit more color on your athletic
background it's it's not like you are
elderly and obese i mean there are
at least no comorbidities that i'm aware
of
that would have put that on the radar
ahead of time right i mean perhaps if
you had your whole genome sequenced you
might have spotted
something or a possibility but if my
notes are correct
in our first conversation we covered
some of your running times and your best
time for the mile
was it 4 minutes 12 seconds something
along those lines
and marathon 2 hours 21 minutes i think
about your life i think about your
experiences
as a journalist in war-torn countries
in some respects embracing risk
and i'm looking at a quote from your
literary agent
of 10-plus years ago i'm not sure if if
he's still your agent but yeah this is
stewart
uh krachewski and the quote is quote
what really motivates him meaning you
are things that terrify him
end quote and certainly
i mean one doesn't have to look long at
your bio to identify
many things that would scare most people
has
the experience the experience you just
described
affected how you think of voluntary
risk or has that aspect of your life not
changed
much the risk-taking has changed
enormously i think it would have just
as a function of getting older and
certainly as a function of being a
father
i mean you have kids and you are the
custodian of your own life
for them it's not your life and i'm not
saying
that you're a martyr in your parenthood
i'm saying that the highest priority
for you as a parent must be to stay
alive
and to provide a loving environment for
them
that's it and you know when you're a
young man or a young person
there's every reason in the world to
pursue very very much your own sort of
ego driven desires and ambitions i mean
that's what you should be doing
and sometimes those include risk taking
i've taken a lot of risks in my life
i'm not at all a thrill seeker so i you
know i drive responsibly and i wear a
seatbelt and all that
but the risks i've taken i was a high
climber for tree companies so i'd be
working 70 80 feet in the air with a
chainsaw taking trees down
you know from the top down that could
that could be dangerous
i mean it can be deadly if you make a
mistake and then i did a lot of war
reporting
and those risks all felt voluntary but
manageable
like if you're smart about it you're in
less danger than if you're stupid about
it you know i felt like i had i saw a
handle
on the risk that i had a vote in the
outcome and then i was an athlete my
whole life and
after i stopped competitive running i
you know in my 50s i started boxing
which is
without exception the hardest thing i've
ever done as a the arrogance of the
distance runner i looked at a boxing
ring
like besides my kitchen how hard can it
be you know
oh my god i couldn't believe it i mean
getting hit getting hits the least of it
at any rate like i started boxing at my
you know
55 year old amateurish level but it was
really good for me
and the doctor you know the doctor said
look if you weren't in
incredible shape you would have died you
would have had it you know your heart
would have stopped your kidneys would
have failed
any other medical issue with you you
would have it's a miracle you survived
as it is if you had
anything else going on you wouldn't be
here
and it made me realize that i was 58
that was the race i've been training for
my whole life that was the boxing match
i've been training for my whole life it
wasn't something in college
it wasn't you know whatever it was when
you lose 90
of your blood and you're in good hands
at the hospital you have a chance of
surviving and
being a father to your daughters and
that was
you know i made i did it like i did it
and i got nothing else to prove and i'm
certainly not going to take any risks
that would jeopardize my daughter's a
chance to have a father
so i'm certainly going to come back to
your daughters because these daughters
were not in the picture
last time we had a conversation on the
podcast so
talk about a phase shift a lot has
changed before we get to that though i
want to ask you a bit about boxing so
you
if you could just repeat when did you
start boxing roughly what age
i think i was 51 i i married now but i
was married before
and that marriage you know we agreed to
not really talk about it publicly but
basically
it ended we're still friends it ended in
a friendly
collaborative fashion the ending of any
marriage is
enormously painful you know particularly
if you care for the person
and we did and it was enormously painful
and i wanted something
i'd always wanted a box and i wanted i
just wanted something to put my mind in
a different place
so i i did two things i started i'd
always wanted to learn accordion
and so i started playing accordion which
is a really hard instrument by the way
and uh uh you have to coordinate the two
hands they're doing
totally different things and it's just
oh my god it took me years to
get that down but the thing that scared
me and here was you know i've done
things that scared me
my whole life and clearly i need
something of that
what terrified me was boxing was getting
into a ring even for friendly sparring
i couldn't believe how frightening it
was and there's no rational reason right
but the
demands on your body i think one could
make an argument there's some pretty
rational reasons
right when it involves getting punched
in the head
but the sparring i was doing with were
with guys
you know my trainer or a friend or
whatever no one wanted around to really
hurt me or vice versa it was very you
know time out like
you know this is too much and that it
stops right i mean the anxiety i would
have was just
unbelievable and the physical demands on
you
are i couldn't really fathom it and that
was why i did it and so and i'm still
doing it you know like it's just clearly
it's a sort of lifeline to something
that i need
what do you think that might be what is
it that that you need what does that
scratch for you
honestly i think i need things in my
life that scare me that i think i can't
do
and then i face my fears and i wind up
being able to do them
and it makes me feel like a little bit
more secure in the universe
and you know keep in mind if the
universe can take you out
on a june afternoon with no warning
for no reason like you any sense of
security that you can get
take it because you'll need it that
makes sense to me
one thing i need some help i not not
help but i would i would like to i
wasn't planning this was not in my list
of questions for you but i did not
foresee the accordion coming up
uh so if you do how of all the
instruments in the world
how did you choose the accordion and
that's not to slight the accordion i'm a
big fan i'm a big fan
there's a there's a variation of the
accordion called the bandogne
in argentina which i was exposed to a
lot so i think
these are beautiful instruments but it's
just not one this is probably the first
time in 500 episodes that the accordion
has come up on this podcast
how did you arrive at the accordion yeah
you know it's just in a lot of the
musical traditions
that i really love it's in eastern
european music my first wife was from
eastern europe
it's in gypsy music and mexican music
and irish music you know i mean all
these traditions that i absolutely adore
and uh and everyone plays the damn
guitar you know what i mean so i
i i i the accordion was it i don't know
you know with the left hand you're
playing the bass line which is
you're basically playing basically
playing the rhythm section
your right hand you're playing the
melody so they're not doing the same
thing
and splitting your mind into these two
different
tasks simultaneously was unbelievably
hard but i heard
i mean this is the aging male talking
now right like i'm 59 i heard
it's actually really good for your brain
you know as you get older to challenge
it with tasks like that's good to offset
all the brain damage from the boxing
probably yeah exactly they can't sleep
each other out yeah exactly
um i gotta say it gives me
a sense of just practicing just playing
a song
like that i'm even that the universe has
even allowed me to place
play a beautiful song is so stunning to
me because it always seems so far beyond
my
capability it almost felt like i wasn't
allowed to and
i realized that i can play danny boy it
you know
that i'm allowed to do that and it will
come out and it sounds beautiful it's so
stunning to me
it gives me a sense of of peace and
completeness
that i think only hope like holding my
holding one of my daughters
is the only thing that kind of rivals
that sense of like ah here i am things
are good
things are calm i love this it was a
pretty extraordinary effect on my life
i've alzheimer's on both sides
of my family and i recall the first time
that i was
sent uh a video program
a link on youtube to a video program and
i'm blanking on the name we'll put it in
the show notes
of alzheimer's patients being played
music
from their adolescents or childhoods
and what was so incredible was not only
what happened when they listened to the
music they went from completely
catatonic in some cases to animated and
singing along
but the persistence of this sort of
cognitive
upgrade for a period of say 30 to 60
minutes afterwards where they could hold
a really coherent conversation
recognize people in contrast to being
completely unable to do so beforehand so
i do think there is
something so elemental and mysterious
about
what music does to the brain and the
personality
i i don't claim to have any answers but
i find it endlessly
interesting let's let's talk about your
daughters as josh put it
to me via text he said he's raising two
young daughters in an extremely
elemental that's where i got the word
mindful tribal manner definitely
explore you're going to recognize this
is josh definitely explore what
fatherhood is teaching him about life
what if his daughters taught him about
tribes so these are
and then the last one uh he said ask him
about how he is structured to sleep with
kids and pets that should be fun
smiley face so i realized this is a a
bit of a hodgepodge of many questions
but yeah what do you think josh means
and is he accurate by saying
elemental mindful tribal manner
well let me just start by saying yeah i
think both music and children
i think one of the things the invaluable
things they do is they give you the
courage to face life
and life is hard and life is scary and
sometimes painful and both of them
in my experience give you this resource
to draw on
that help you face it and so it is
actually a very good segue for me to go
from music to
to children i think there's some real
similarities there's something about
not living for yourself any longer
that's enormously liberating
you know i think that's one of the
things you know i spent a lot of time in
combat and in combat
with american soldiers actually and i
think one of the things that was
drew these guys to war you know often
after a bad deployment you know a lot of
them sort of missed it
and i think what drew them was the loss
of the experience of losing your
the the primacy of yourself as the most
important thing of your
in your life you lose that when you're
in a platoon i mean you really have to
think in terms of the group and you
first you might imagine that that's a
loss it's actually
you gain by doing that the focus on the
self
can be enormously tormenting and make
people incredibly anxious like it's not
a good place to go
children allow you to do that for better
or worse you know sometimes you know
it's
it's not always fun it can be pretty
hectic and insane actually but
at the end of the day either because
you're overwhelmed with tasks or
overwhelmed with love you are thinking
about something else not yourself and
they are the most important thing and
so it totally reorders your place in the
world
and i've loved it i i think at age 25 i
might not have loved it you know i mean
i think i had to be in my 50s to do this
gracefully and well
but here i am and so why do you say that
not not to interrupt but i will
uh why do you say that about uh
your age and that possibility
now or at least in the last handful of
years as opposed to earlier
you know i grew up in a very safe pretty
affluent
society in a suburb of boston and i had
this enormous craving to experience the
world and particularly the
the risks and thrills that it offered
you know of all kinds
and you know i i could have had children
when i was doing that but it would i
wouldn't have been a very good father
and so now you know that i've i've
experienced the world sufficiently
like i don't you know like i don't i
don't need any more of that information
and it has allowed me to completely
devote my self to being a good dad and a
good partner
part of that means you know i have to
work i need to earn a living it's not
like all i do is
i have to focus on a lot of other things
but
at the end of the day there's really
only one thing that that is
powerfully interesting to me and it's my
family now it's not my work it's nothing
it's them
i don't think i could have or maybe even
should have done that at 25.
how do you think about raising them or
parenting or fathering to josh's
list of attractive adjectives elemental
mindful tribal manner
do you think that do you think that's
accurate yeah it is i mean you know i
started anthropology in college
i've been in the developing world an
awful lot you don't have to do too much
research
to realize basically the british
legacy of parenting that we have is very
rare
so in most of the world parents sleep
with their young children
in the same room even in the same bed
humans are primates
young primates are very vulnerable in
nature
and they know that if they're alone in a
dark room
or anywhere that they're in a lot of
danger and they cry
and one of the odd things about
english-style parenting
again which is basically what we have in
america is that when children get put in
a room to go to sleep
and they cry nothing happens no one goes
in to comfort them i mean that's
called sleep training and it can be done
right i mean eventually the kid stops
crying
but if you think about it this way if
you were backpacking with your family in
the bob marshall wilderness
in montana and you had a six month old
or two-year-old or a five-year-old
you probably wouldn't put them in a
different tent
right right they'd sleep with you right
it's a scary environment well the six
month old doesn't know that their
bedroom is not a scary environment
it's dark there's dangers out there you
know and all that fear is wired into us
so
the contemporary term for something
that's you know has been around for
hundreds of thousands of years but now
we have a term for
it co-sleeping that used to just be what
sleeping was but
called co-sleeping with your kids we've
never owned a stroller
i walk around with my kids on my
shoulders or in my chest there's a lot
of physical contact you know what i sort
of realized is
that if there is physical contact
between the parent and the child
it's very hard to monetize that so if if
you're a company and wants to make
things for parents things for children
you can't monetize
a mother holding their child and nursing
there's no way to get in there
to charge money for it right as soon as
you have
people that are sleeping separately from
their kids you need cribs
you need play pens you need video
monitors you need all this stuff as soon
as you
have parents who are not willing to
carry their children you need strollers
some of those things cost a thousand
dollars like if you sort of look at it
in sort of capitalist terms and i'm you
know whatever i'm not a socialist i'm
just trying to analyze something which
is
unique in the world like our society
starting maybe around 100 years ago
started parenting in a radically
different way
it happened to be in a way that can be
monetized to the tune
of hundreds of millions of billion
dollars a year industry
you have to separate the parent from the
child particularly from the mother in
order to monetize it and i think that's
basically what's happened and so we just
don't do that and
we share my wife and i share the burdens
of the challenges
and thrills of parenting equally like a
fully involved father
but we don't have any of that stuff and
you know i gotta say i mean i know it's
a data point of one but
you know we have two very very happy
secure non-anxious little girls like i
mean it's just amazing to see them
really have almost no anxiety about the
world and about whether
we're with them or not we can leave them
with a friend and walk away and like
there's no they don't even blink so much
that we could unpack that we might come
back to unpack
in this conversation i i'd like to jump
to
something you said earlier and that was
i'm saying
a b and c i can't recall exactly what it
was but as an aging male
so one of josh is not to turn this into
the might as well have josh doing this
interview
but he knows you well and i like to
cheat
so his one of his questions was how does
he
meaning sebastian relate to the aging
process of a warrior
and then i'm gonna need a pronunciation
check here i did actually look
up who this person is but ask him about
plenty coops on that theme
is that the correct pronunciation but
plenty cool
there you go yeah it's a french word
betraying my lack of french
i would love to hear your thoughts on
this because you certainly strike me as
someone
who sort of embodies i suppose
we all do or at least most males do some
warrior dna or ethos and you've spent a
lot of time
among people on front lines on
deployment
yeah so how do you how would you answer
that question
and i suppose we should explain who
pleniku is
at some point he was he was a crow
indian
chief and war leader and visionary so
society every society needs a lot of
different kinds of people they need
mothers they need fathers they need
warriors they need grandmothers and
grandparents
grandfathers they need wise people
they need people who are really good at
just working you know i mean there's a
lot of different things that need to
happen in a society
all the way from hunter-gatherer to
modern mass industrial society that we
have today
a lot of different things are needed and
warriors are one of them
it's a dangerous world there's predators
there's enemies
and even in a society where
i mean we're not in here in new york
city where i am we're not going to be
invaded at the moment
and there are no animal predators but
fires kill people i mean there are
structural fires that can kill whole
families right so we have firemen
who live in firehouses who who will risk
their lives collectively to save people
they don't know at all
they're warriors in that sense society
needs all of this they don't have to be
male often they are for some
pretty obvious biological reasons but
they don't have to be male
we all remember joan of arc of course
but
that requires a couple of things to do
well
first of all being a warrior in that
broad sense requires
being in very good physical condition so
as you and as you get older
a lot of processes happen in your body
and you're not as fast you're not as
strong
you're not as coordinated you're not
your reflexes aren't as good i mean
everything
everything goes downhill you don't want
70 year olds trying to be warriors they
just won't be as good at it as they were
when they were 20.
but also there's this other thing you
know as you get older your ties
to life get stronger and stronger you
have
a place in the community you have
children you might have a business
you have whatever you get the things
that keep you moored
to your existence emotionally
psychologically
those things are more numerous and
they're stronger and
when you're a 20 year old i think
particularly for a guy but i think it's
either sex but i think particularly for
young men your 20 year old guy
you're not moored to much you know like
all those things
for most 20 year old men 20 year old
people those things haven't started
happening yet
so if you want to put them in a warrior
mode where they might lose their life
you know for me
i'm okay losing my life for myself right
i mean there are things worth gambling
one's life for
as far as i myself am concerned i sure
am not going to gamble
my daughter's ability to have a father
for much
right i think i might only only risk my
life
to defend them to protect them like that
might be the only thing i would risk my
life for
at this point when i was 25 i might well
risk my life for a buddy or whatever
like
i'm not you know no one else is paying
the cost of me dying so
i can make that choice on my own and so
what you have to do
as a warrior even just as a human being
is you have to transition from a sort of
i'm making all my own decisions i don't
owe
anything to anyone any explanation to
anyone
to transition from that to okay there's
younger guys
there's younger guys out there they can
they can out punch me they can outrun me
they definitely get noticed by young
women a whole lot more than i have like
oh your son is the sun is setting on
your world
so what does that mean does it just mean
you you are
are used up and useless no it doesn't
and the the amazing thing about plenty
coup the story the value i saw in that
story and i'll tell it in a moment
was that it was a perfect metaphor for
getting older
and maintaining your your utility not to
mention your dignity so
there's an amazing book called radical
hope it's not a self-help book although
it sounds like it is it's a work of
philosophy and anthropology
and it's about the life of plenty coup
and i can't remember the author's name
because i'm 59 and names just slip out
of my mind but but uh
it's a short book and it's an incredible
book
and it's about plenty coo and how he
went from being this warrior
i mean the the big threat when he was a
young man fighting
was white society right they were coming
the railroads were coming they
telegraphed lines the cowboys it was all
coming
across the plains towards crowe society
and the sioux for example were very very
warlike like the crow and they
they fought to the bitter end what
plenty coup realized was that the
ultimate job
of the warrior is to protect their
society
and for all of crow history that meant
fighting to the death if need be to
protect
your community right but this was
a different moment in history everything
had changed
and fighting white society to the death
would mean that your society was going
to get killed
too your community was going to get
wiped out there was a lot of killing of
women and children
in these battles that happened in the
great plains in the 1760s 1770s 1780s
non-combatants really weren't spared so
if you fought to the death
against the seventh cavalry you were
really risking everybody
and so what plenty coup realized was
that
in keeping with the ultimate warrior
role of preserving at all costs
preserving your community
in this case in this new history this
new moment of history this new era
it actually meant not fighting fighting
was the thing
that would get your people killed not
fighting
was the thing that might save them when
he figured it out he said learning to
read
and learning to farm were the new
callings of the warrior
those things would best preserve the
people
and the community that the warriors
loved and they would have to get over
their own ego
and their own sense of well i'm nothing
if i'm not a warrior they have to get
over that
in order to truly do their job as a
warrior and protect the people they love
and for me that was a you know i read
that book in my mid-40s
just when the knees were starting to
hurt a bit you know that whatever
just the hair was starting to to leave
the top of my head you know right at
those those changes just started
happening in your 40s
and uh and i read that book then i was
like oh my god
this is it like there's a stage in one's
life when being a warrior means actually
not being in that aggressive physical
confrontational
super physical role is actually
something softer and wiser
and ultimately more enduring that you
can choose
the book you mentioned radical hope
subtitle ethics in the face of cultural
devastation
jonathan lear appears to be yeah
the author of that book i was reading
the
wikipedia entry on plenty
coup i'm so self-self-con now
uh yeah french is not my strong suit but
his adult
crow name or the name that was bestowed
upon him was
many achievements and the entire entry
is really
really fascinating there's a strong
component we don't necessarily have to
get into this but a strong component
at least in his story and these could be
apocryphal
or just mythologies but there's a
consistent component
of visions and fasting leading to
visions
dictating his decisions which which i
found very interesting in this entry at
least
not that i can parse that well i can i
can jump in and tell you
so he his transformation his moment of
enlightenment came following a vision
that he had it was
our dream vision and i can't remember
what it was
but jonathan lear just does this
brilliant job at deconstructing it and
explaining how all this works and
you know lear is a philosopher he's a
very clearly a very smart guy
i've read we all have read a lot of
amazing books but that book really
it caught me at the right moment in my
life and it really um
it was one of the most important books
i've ever read that's on the list
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008
crisis you would have missed out on 50
percent five zero percent of your
returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested in a long-term
automated investment portfolio
wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
it takes about three minutes to sign up
and then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your
risk appetite and manage it for you at
an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay
on your investment gains their newest
service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life
that's wealthfront.comtim wealthfront
will automate your investments for the
long term
and you can get started today at
wealthfront.com
tim
let's look at and talk about
freedom i'm sure we'll bounce around a
lot
my understanding and please correct me
if i'm getting this wrong
but i don't think we discussed this in
our first podcast conversation that
when you were younger you hitchhiked
across the country this was some time
ago
freedom describes this new book
something very very different
what was the catalyst or the the impetus
behind
what became freedom like did it did it
start as
a plan for experience and experiences
sake
did it begin with a fascination or a
question related to this word this
concept of freedom
what's the genesis story and then the
reason i brought up the hitchhiking is
i'd just be curious to know how that
experience
contrasts with uh some of the
experiences described
i came to the idea to write a book about
freedom partly just
by noticing that people use and misuse
that word
all the time it's an extremely potent
word
it's like the word tribe i mean you say
the word tribe the word freedom these
are
elemental human values and they go to
the core
of the human experience and
can be misconstrued and used to justify
awful things so easily but they can also
be
used very beautifully to preserve human
dignity
and to safeguard the things that we all
live for and so i just
sort of became interested in the word
it's extremely hard to define so if you
go
you know if you look it up in the
dictionary the definition of freedom is
is almost non-intelligible i mean
it's like defining the word and i mean
it's extremely abstract but it's
something that we
all in our hearts in our guts we sort of
know what it
means and we know why we want to be free
we
we know why it's intolerable not to be
and so i just started thinking about it
and
you know i didn't want to write a i'm
not jonathan lear
i didn't want to write a philosophical
inquiry and i certainly didn't want to
write a political tract i mean the word
is misused in politics all the time in a
sort of hideous grotesque way and i
didn't you know i didn't want to wade
into the political battles
around that word i was interested in
literally
through the course of human experience
how do people maintain their freedom
and what that basically means is how do
you maintain your autonomy in the face
of a larger power
if you're the most powerful thing in the
room your freedom is not in
question it's not in danger freedom
becomes a
an important word when there is a
more powerful entity that might
try to deprive you of your choices of
the quality of your circumstances
and throughout history how have people
avoided that because there are powerful
societies
and there are weak societies that were
large strong men and there are smaller
men or women
the universe isn't fair and and things
are not divided equally and
there's rich societies and poor society
so how did the how did the
the underdogs manage to maintain their
freedom from the
the groups that could oppress them or
try to
so there's three basic ways my book is
divided into three sections for this
reason run
fight and think so the first thing you
can do
is just stay out of the reach of your
oppressor so
for example in the american southwest in
the 1540s i think it was the spanish
first showed up coronado explorer showed
up
and you know that he encountered two
different kinds of native societies
there were the pueblo tribes that lived
in these sort of thick-walled houses on
top of mesas they had they were
agriculturalists
they were quite wealthy they stayed
where they were they were like little
they were like little villages in spain
i mean they were
at almost european feudal european level
of social evolution
economic evolution and then there were
the the apache
and the navajo they didn't stay anywhere
for very long they were extremely
they were materially poor i mean they
only owned what they could carry
they hunted and they were extremely
mobile they lived in brush
huts that they threw up in a few minutes
in western terms they were very poor
people but what happened so when the
spanish showed up and then later the
americans
the pueblo tribes got rolled immediately
i mean sometimes within a few hours of
confronting the spaniards they couldn't
out fight them and they were stuck in
their villages and
they would give up or they would be
defeated and massacred
the apache remained free for
you know another 300 plus years the last
of the apache of the free apache were
not sort of cornered
and controlled by the us government
until the
end of the 1880s i mean my grandmother
was almost alive by then you know she
was born in 1900
you were really almost in the modern era
at this point the machine guns been
invented
the light bulb the internal combustion
engine
i think the telephone i mean i i can't
remember basically all the modern
appliances that we think of like they've
already been invented at this point in
the apache
are still running around free and it's
because they're so mobile
so i write about that and just the
human's ability to run i mean we
from sprint to long distance if you take
the full range of human running ability
we outstrip just about every animal
particularly in the heat the record for
running a thousand miles
is around 10 days i mean someone ran 100
miles a day for
for 10 days ran a thousand miles like
it's something like that i can't
remember exactly so
fight was about literally about fighting
and the interesting thing about humans
and we're just about unique in the
animal kingdom
that a small individual can actually out
fight a larger one that's not true with
elk and grizzly bear and everything else
but with humans size is a terrible
predictor of outcome in individual
combat
i looked at statistics from the ufc
mixed martial arts fighting and larger
men
when paired against smaller men win
about 50 percent of the time
in other words if size is not a
predictor of outcome you know likewise
small insurgencies like the taliban
can outlast and out fight larger
established militaries like the us
military i mean the taliban
no tanks no artillery obviously no air
force and some of them didn't even have
boots
and they bought the most powerful
military in the world
to a standstill and we are now
negotiating for peace with them
basically
and they'd already done the same thing
to the russians if smaller entities
could not
outfight larger ones freedom would not
be possible i mean the world would be
run by
the largest or violent male is true for
chimpanzees
alpha male and history would just be
dominated by
large oppressive powerful societies they
definitely have it undo
a disproportionate influence on world
events
but those kinds of large societies
cannot be sure that they can dominate
the smaller ones and if that were not
true
freedom would not be possible america
would not exist for example
england would have crushed us during the
revolution and then again in 1812.
you know finally in a situation where
you you can't outrun or outfight them
like the labor movement in america
in the early part of the 20th century
you have to out-think them
you have to out-think the powerful
entity and that can be done as well it's
extremely effective in the last part of
my book i go into
the traits that smaller successful
entities the traits they have in common
that allow them to overcome a more
powerful adversary
they include women in their group it's a
very very common
trait that is needed the leadership has
to be selfless
the leadership cannot just send the
warriors out to die while they're back
on a hilltop
the leadership has to metaphorically and
literally face the bullets first
and you need to have a sense of history
like that we are
we're fighting impossible odds but
history demands that we do there has to
feel like there's a higher calling
religion can provide that i'm not
religious myself but it's a very
effective way of giving people a sense
of a higher calling
and national suffering i mean you sort
of tradition of national suffering the
way you had in ireland
the potato famine and the oppression by
the english can inspire people
to give up their lives to fight
something that
they probably can't even win but if they
don't fight they certainly won't win
and as often as not that actually works
two things i'd love to mention and one
could be actually both well i'm sure be
hopping off points but the first is
you mentioned the inclusion of women in
resistance or insurgencies and that is
not just
a polite inclusion it is a pragmatic
inclusion but there's a quote i don't
remember who it was from something along
the lines of it takes
or one police officer can handle 10 men
but it takes 10 police officers to
handle one woman in part because
there is in many cultures at least a
hesitancy to inflict violence upon women
and therefore they can be
extremely tactically powerful
is that uh fair to say the participation
of women in these movements is
absolutely crucial and you know even for
the taliban they were
there were no i don't think any female
taliban fighters
but women hold society together and
insurgencies are rooted in society if
the society isn't functioning
there is no insurgency and so even at
that level women are
absolutely necessary as ammunition or
whatever like they're absolutely crucial
to any endeavor like that but at the
more tactical level
the quote you're referring to about the
policeman was during the mill strikes in
massachusetts
ah uh massachusetts in lawrence
massachusetts yeah lawrence
massachusetts in
uh 1912. and you know they they'd have
the guys out there
and you know the strikes happened
because the living conditions were
unspeakably bad the wages were not even
survival wages
one in five infants died among the
worker populations one in five infants
died before the age of
two i mean i mean for a democratic
country within the 20th century
that that was happening was just
revolting and
they rose up and as long as they had a
bunch of guys in the street the cops
could get as rough as they wanted they
fixed their bayonets they aimed their
rifles
people got shot people got beaten no
problem
so the striker started putting women on
the front lines and of course the
cops i mean a lot of these cops are 20
year old boys they have mothers
that age or sisters or whatever they're
not you know
getting young men to kill women is very
hard to do
and particularly up close like that and
so so essentially once they put women on
the front line the police didn't know
what to do and that's where that quote
came from it takes 10 cops to handle one
woman women also give a
situation like that a kind of moral
authority i mean you have a bunch of
guys on the street it can
be just mistaken for a violent mob once
you have women in there it's not a
violent
rightly or wrongly many societies our
society certainly
believes that women are abhor violence
and want
what is good for the world and for
children so here you put women in the
mix
and suddenly it's harder to sort of
refute the legitimacy of the cause
they also have this other thing which is
sort of amazing is that for a variety of
cultural reasons
women are they're harder to sort of
scrutinize i mean even frisking a woman
in public is
complicated for a male cop and sometimes
i mean i've heard that there are female
bouncers in some clubs because men just
don't want to get in a fist fight with a
woman it just looks too
too bad for them so there is this sort
of tactical level of using women
but women have these lateral connections
within society
that can be exploited for communication
for spying
and it's very hard for the authorities
to penetrate these
lateral female social networks
particularly in ghettos
and in the the slums that these workers
were living in
it was very very hard for the cops to
penetrate that and
sort of eavesdrop on the movement
whereas men
what they have they're terrible at those
lateral connections what they're very
good at is hierarchy
so if you have a sort of leader who's
got
a male following as a male coalition
that he's heading up
and that guy says i can have 500 men on
the street at 6am tomorrow morning
gunfire or no gunfire those guys will
follow
orders and that sort of top-down
hierarchy that will run into gunfire if
need be
that is ben are very good at that and so
you combine those two qualities
male hierarchy and female sort of
lateral affiliation
you're presenting the authorities with
an incredibly
complicated tactical problem that has
very few good solutions
let's talk about not necessarily
hitchhiking but i want to talk about the
parallel connective tissue that is used
to weave the story
that is told or the stories that are
told in freedom and i'll
read a paragraph that i quite like
and then you can elaborate if if you
wouldn't mind
this conversation uh we called our trip
the last patrol
and it seemed like a long hard weird
thing to do until we were actually out
there where suddenly it was so obvious
we rarely even caught ourselves
wondering why we were doing it
the things that had to happen out there
were so clear and simple
eat walk hide sleep that just getting
through the day felt like scripture
a true and honest accounting of
everything that underlies the frantic
performance
of life so of course i'm leaving out
exactly what we're talking about uh
what am i talking about what is this
referring to and
how did it come to be yeah
so freedom is a mix of these
this research that i did into how people
maintain their freedom
and this trip that we took the last
patrol and the sections cut back and
forth i
talk about the last patrol because it
was
probably the freest i've ever been in a
sort of physical sense
you know as i say somewhere in the book
we
walked 400 miles along the railroad
lines and
you know we were sleeping under bridges
and in the woods and
in abandoned buildings and sort of no
man's land
along the railroad lines and we walked
400 miles and most nights we were the
only people who knew where we were
there are many definitions of freedom
but surely that's one of them and it was
one that i had the um
real good luck to be able to experience
for a little while uh
so i have to go back to 2009 to explain
this i was
i spent a year off and on with a platoon
in combat
in afghanistan my colleague out there
was his name was tim hetherington he was
a british photographer
we shot you know we shot a ton of video
out there and we collaborated
and made a documentary called restrepo
that was
nominated for an oscar it did quite well
and it was just about what it was like
to be in combat
and sentence like there was no politics
no strategy
just what's it like to be an american
platoon in a firefight just about every
day
so we were at one point we were tim and
i were taking the train down to
to washington dc to talk to national
geographic because we were trying to
sell this thing we didn't have a
buyer yet we just shot a lot of video
and wanted to make this film and
on the way down i was looking out the
window and um the entire way
i realized that there was a we were
looking for our next project after
restrepo right we're already looking
ahead and i was looking
i saw along the train tracks that you
could walk
almost the entire way there was a dirt
bike trail or a cinder maintenance road
or a corn field or a whatever like
you could kind of do it and i said to
tim i was like listen man let's walk
from dc to new york along the railroad
lines and let's just see what happens
and tragically after we made restrepo
and it was very successful we were at
the oscars on the red carpet
and this is almost exactly 10 years ago
the arab spring was
boiling away and tim and i are
journalists right we serve we're on this
we're in this sort of beautiful
luxurious world of hollywood
with our film but meanwhile you know
surf's up
elsewhere in the world you know i was
like dude we got to get back out there
and we
we decided to go on assignment to cover
the civil war in libya at the last
minute i couldn't go and he went on his
own and he was killed in the city of
misrata
on april 20 10 years ago and so this is
always a very sad time of year for me
i should have been on the trip with him
had i been i probably would have been
killed
alongside him had i gone maybe i could
have saved him
i felt a huge amount of guilt about it
it took me a long time to get over his
death
and he bled out he bled out like i
almost did except he bled out onto the
ground
i bled out into my abdomen and there was
a doctor there to save me for him that
wasn't
the only difference after that i was
reeling
reeling from a lot of things but from
tim's death and particularly and i
thought i know what i'm going to do
i'm going to do that project i'm going
to walk the railroad lines
i'm going to take two guys from restrepo
that we tim and i knew really well
and i'm going to take the journalist who
was with tim when he died
guillermo cervera a spanish photographer
amazing amazing photographer
he was holding tim's hand when tim died
in the back of a pickup truck and so i
got to know guillermo very well and so i
convinced these guys to walk 400 by
400 miles on the railroad lines we did
it in chunks throughout a year
over the course of a year we did we
weren't hitching freights right we were
walking
i picked railroad lines because it's
counter-intuitively it's safer like you
walk along roads you can get hit by a
car really
really easily but also they're not
monitored i mean you're not going to get
picked up for vagrancy because there's
no cops on railroad lines there's no
security cameras there's no lights
there's nothing it's no man's land and
you
you beat some weird cats out there but
everyone's sort of on their own
and and it's just this weird no man's
lane where you can kind of sleep
wherever you want there's
abandoned buildings there's patches of
weeds there's
whatever you just make it work and we
got to see america from the inside out
we walked right through the ghettos
right through the farms right through
the
industrial wastelands we hit
philadelphia
and instead of going to new york decided
to head west and we walked
to pittsburgh the last patrol was my
experience with freedom
of a certain sort and my book
intercuts sections about that amazing
trip
with the real inquiries that i did into
how one maintains one's freedom in the
face of a more powerful adversary
how did the structure of this book
change from initial conception
to finish product if it did i mean i
know
i know based on our previous
conversations that you think a lot about
structure
how did this book change over time did
you expect it to be one thing and then
it ended up being
quite a different thing or from the
get-go did you have a pretty
crystallized vision of what the finished
book would look like
i had the idea that no one would want to
read a whole book about the last patrol
and i had the idea that no one would
want to
read a whole book about these sort of
technical or historical topics
of run fight think i mean i don't quite
have malcolm gladwell's
adept hand at presenting these sort of
arcane topics you know i mean
i mean i could do it for a few pages i
can't do it for a full length book so i
just thought
you know what i'll do is i'll combine
them and
i'll combine them in such a way where my
experience out on the railroad lines
is interwoven in these more abstract
ideas
and so i have i think i have a good
sense of you know after a thousand words
or so the reader wants something a
little different like a palette cleanser
the structure for the book didn't change
much actually i just
thought i'm gonna i'm gonna start with
our walking and then when
i written a chunk of that that feels
dramatically complete
thousand words or so i'll jump to the
first topic and one of the things i
wanted to write about was america
because we're walking right through it
and we walked through what had been the
pennsylvania frontier in the
1600s 1700s life on the frontier
was supposed to be very free that's the
sort of american myth
it was very free from government it was
not free from danger and as a result
these communities on the frontier in
pennsylvania
banded together in ways that were
oppressive in their you know the
expectations if you were part of a
frontier community the expectations
placed on you by the community
in terms of group mutual defense were
enormous so
i just started playing with this idea of
explaining american history in terms
of people choosing one kind of freedom
over another they left the oppression of
the government
the colonial governments and they wound
up in the oppression of small
communities where if you were a man and
you didn't have a you didn't
you had to carry your rifle and a
scalping knife white people scalped back
then as well of course
and a tomahawk at all times you had to
have a rifle
a tomahawk and a scalping knife and
because you had to be ready
to fight at any moment and if you if you
were caught without those things
you were ostracized you know they had a
kind of freedom on the frontier
but you're never completely free because
if you're alone you're in too much
you're in danger and that doesn't work
so
you know i had this idea of sort of
mixing these
my trip and what i came to understand
about being alone and vulnerable
in this very small group and very
vulnerable in a hostile environment
mixing that with the just eternal human
endeavor of making a society and
surviving and raising your children and
not getting killed
you know i i'd love to ask you not to
turn this into a personal therapy
session but why not
um you know you mentioned the the death
of your friend tim
we've talked about warfare
you write very eloquently and powerfully
about
many things one of which is brutality
right human on human brutality
and one thing that is very clear
in your writing is that no one group
has a monopoly on like human on human
brutality i mean if you look at
the history of different native american
tribes certainly there was
intense conflict many rivalries you had
the settled
tribes and then you had the raiding
cultures you know many of which could
not necessarily coexist certainly with
settlers and then
various forms of torture that you've
written about i'm currently reading
a book that deals largely with
environmental concerns
and deforestation and all sorts of
tragedies related to
violations against nature and i find
myself
maybe this is just a weakness of
character but like growing kind of
despondent
where it just seems like it seems like
the dye has been cast
and whether it's by through evolution or
willful blindness the golf ball's been
hit
and it can't be unhit in certain ways
have you ever experienced that i'm
wondering if you've ever experienced it
or kind of
what keeps the lights on for you
and again maybe this is unique to me but
there are times where i'm just i
really feel kind of overwhelmed by these
things
and that there's so little to stem the
tide of these various
tragedies how do you relate to that
or not well we're primates
we're very violent primates we're also
very affiliative primates
there's no kind of violence that humans
haven't committed
and that some humans enjoy committing
but
by equal measure there's no kind of
generosity
and heroism and nobility
and dignity that humans are capable of
committing
even at the loss of their own life
violence begets violence
you torture someone they get their hands
on one
someone from your group they're going to
torture that you know i mean that
that's how it works i saw i seen it work
that way in combat
over and over and over again the rage at
the enemy that would kill your buddy
or your wife or your child there's this
homicidal rage
that someone would do that to you
turns you into someone who would do that
to them and then you're off and running
and that's
ubiquitous in the world i have to assume
that that kind of enraged violent
response is adaptive it helps
communities survive in the face of a
dire threat
that a more passive okay you can take me
prisoner you can
turn us into into slaves you can kill us
but we're not going to raise a hand
against you that that was weeded out
whatever genes would get someone to do
that were weeded out pretty
pretty quickly in the human race by the
same token
if we were just a society of sort of
like violent brutes
we wouldn't have survived either and in
these beautiful human values of
caretaking
and particularly caretaking the helpless
young shouldering the elderly just
people who are unfortunate
even enemy enemies that are unfortunate
that fall into our
care they're often cared for very very
well right so there's this human
these twin human impulses in freedom
you know i talk a little bit about the
native americans
because they practice the most
indescribably horrific torture
partly as a way of keeping white people
from infiltrating their land and taking
it right so they were trying
to be scary and it worked to a degree it
worked but of course
western society is equally full of
hideous tortures the spanish inquisition
etc and you know i'm i have here a print
out of a
horrible newspaper article from february
8 1904
the vicksburg evening post they you know
it's just an incident that's long been
forgotten i guess but it's a
it was a black couple who were caught
and charged with something that
they probably didn't do and they burned
them alive
in vicksburg and before they did that
they one by one cut off all their
fingers
and then tortured them with corkscrews
you know these are americans
american citizens within my
grandmother's lifetime so
the point is that no society has a
monopoly on violence or on moral
behavior
we're all equally amazing and equally
horrible
and i think that the task of any society
is to be well defended enough so that
you don't get overrun by the
you know by the barbarians but gentle
and kind and loving enough so that
you can provide a moral existence within
your community
and for your children and hopefully
within the world
very hard to do obviously because we
keep screwing it up but i think that is
the
goal and i think that's most people's
goal frankly yeah maybe i'm just
yeah i think i'm i'm going through a
stretch where i'm
i'm having trouble kind of or i don't
want to say blinded by
but like the density of the fog of
brutality that i've been exposed to
voluntarily through
a lot of my own reading and watching
it's just
so heavy i think i probably need to
watch more pixar movies for a while
something like that but all of those
episodes in in our society and our
history
enormously brutal but they also
because people are what they are that
brutality engenders
enormously heroic loving acts as well i
mean in equal measure
there were europeans during world war ii
who were hiding jews in their basement
at risk of being executed by the nazis
people who were otherwise would have
been fined because they weren't jewish
and they were hiding families in their
basements strangers people they didn't
even know
what lesson are you going to take from
world war ii
that the soldiers that landed on d-day
to stop fascism
from taking over the world the first
boats the first landing craft that hit
the beaches ninety percent of those guys
died
ninety yeah a horrific situation but
think about the courage
and the their determination to preserve
the world of moral
world order i would just say that you
can look at the same things through the
other end of the telescope
you're going to see very different
things and ones that will inspire you
and comfort you there's a i want to call
it a quote a line
at the very very beginning in the front
matter of freedom
from ecclesiastes 3 18 as for humans
god tests them so they may know they are
animals
why did you include that
well i'm an atheist
my father was an atheist and
sometimes when atheists read the bible
they see passages
that seem to undermine the central one
of the central tenets of christianity
which is that humans aren't animals
and that there's somehow a different set
of standards a different set of
metrics a different reality for human
beings
and for the rest of the animal kingdom
that were somehow special and that
we were special because we were made by
god and i just thought it was really
helpful
to find the bible itself reminding us
that we might aspire to godly qualities
i hope we all do for the most part
they're good qualities
but at the end of the day the bible
wants us to know that we are animals
and from dust we came and to dust we
shall return
it's very very good to remember that
because when you think
that you're special there's a risk
there's a danger
that you can permit yourself special
things special rights
and those special rights usually don't
end very well
and what we were doing on the last
patrol
was so so physical we were reduced to
such an animal existence
and the fight for freedom that people
throughout history and prehistory have
waged
the physical and psychological fight for
freedom
is so been so brutal that only
only an animal could survive it only an
animal could do it and
the reason we have been able to do it we
as humans is because we are animals
i don't mean it as a criticism i
actually mean it as a compliment to us
all
you've also written very eloquently
about
how if we and i'm taking some liberty
here with
connecting a few dots from from
different uh
portions here but how dehumanization
or viewing a certain sub-population is
sub-human
or animal-like gives you special
permission
to do things you wouldn't otherwise view
as permitable
right whether that be slavery or torture
or
fill in the blank right right i mean if
you if you feel like you're serving
god's will
by liberating a piece of territory
taking over a building wiping out a
a group of people that your society has
decided
are evil if you think you're doing god's
will you don't have to stop and examine
the actual morality of what you're doing
i mean murder is wrong
in almost all circumstances and
mass murder is wrong in all
circumstances but if you're doing god's
will
then of course you don't have to dwell
on that and one way
to reinforce that idea killing costs to
people psychologically it's hard to do
and people even murderers bear the scars
for their lifetimes
and so if you can convince yourself that
the people you're killing
aren't really human then you don't have
to struggle with the moral implications
of
of murder right which is clearly
a sin that god is against so very very
naturally in war i mean it happens
spontaneously
and then gets sort of codified in
mythology around
a war and even in the laws around the
war
but very naturally in war you start to
see the enemy
as not quite human and that's very
convenient because
natural law in the christian tradition
holds that all humans were made by god
or god's god's creatures right so
here you are killing god's creatures
that's probably not a good thing so what
do you
how do you solve that problem you say oh
great yeah we'll follow natural law
but those people over there they're not
really god's creatures because they're
animals
they're parasites they're cockroaches
they're insects they're what
i mean the words that people have used
during genocide
did many genocides in human history to
describe the people they were killing
invariably revert to the rest of the
animal kingdom
like animals and insects and then you
know then you're not you don't have to
be unduly troubled by
the moral issues that come from killing
a hundred thousand people
because you're not really killing people
and that and that little
mental mental trick has allowed you know
ordinarily otherwise decent people to do
things that are completely
heinous and unconscionable without going
mad
let's come back to this word freedom as
you mentioned it's
it's misused it's abused it's
deliberately used
in politics in a contorted way for
various
ends it's also in some ways
defined in so many different ways so
subjectively that
it becomes difficult to to pin down
objectively
but there's a concept or i should say
more accurately
coefficient let's see if i can
mispronounce this too
that i'd never come across before
the book freedom and that is the genie
coefficient or genie coefficients
could you please explain what that is
let me just tee this up a little bit i
think by talking about the
etymology of the word freedom it's
almost a little demoralizing when
if you if you come to understand what
the word is rooted in it comes from
vreedom v-r-i-d-o-m is
middle german for freedom and it's
related to the word beloved
so in an earlier epoch human epoch
freedom was thought of as something that
you only owed
the people that you love the people in
your community the people in your tribe
the people in your family in your clan
those people deserve freedom everyone
else
was eligible for enslavement or worse
you're talking about a circumstance
where once freedom
a it's not a human universal it's not a
universal right
but b you only enjoy freedom because
your little group
is able to protect itself from other
groups that think
exactly the same way about you that
you're eligible for enslavement or death
so freedom is in that ancient sense
is inseparable from the ability to
defend yourself
physically with force with violence from
an attacker
and if you can't because there were no
human
universal laws universal laws of human
rights human dignity
if you couldn't defend yourself you
would probably wind up
being enslaved or killed by a more
powerful adversary and
it's important to keep in mind with the
word freedom that it's rooted in
a arguably ghastly distinction between
us and them
and that you're not going to be free
unless you can defend yourself
there was a around 5 000 years ago
in spain there was a neolithic
population they were agriculturalists
they were quite
peaceful people in the iberian peninsula
and around 5000 years ago they were
invaded by a group called the yamnaya
from the russian steppe and the yamanaya
had horses that pulled chariots
and the iberians had never even seen
horses before much less
ridden them and the yamnaya came in
and over the course of a hundred years
or so seemed to have
wiped out the entire male population of
iberia
and clearly mated with the young women
because in today's iberia
there is no genetic material from
neolithic iberia
that's native to iberia on the male line
it is all
yamanaya and then other other groups
that came in after that
so basically the men of iberia were not
able to defend themselves against the
yamnaya
and they were scrubbed from the human
gene pool and their women were subject
to
ours obviously but their dna is still
here
that's the problem with not being able
to defend yourself
so now you if you sort of go forward a
little bit from there
as agricultural societies took over
they supplanted you know there's around
ten thousand years ago eight thousand
years ago the first
crop started to be planted and people
started to go from a hunter-gatherer
society like the apache where
there was very little discrepancy
between rich and poor
because no one really could own more
than they could carry
and in these hunter-gatherer societies
what they found i read a study of north
american
native societies the native tribes that
were able to
stockpile food or control
access to food production like literally
controlling the points along the pacific
coast where you can fish for salmon
effectively
as soon as that food production could be
controlled and food stockpiled
you started to have a ruling class and
income disparity and power disparities
within one's own society
so with the genie efficient genie is was
the name of an italian
economist from the early 1900s
i can't remember his first name but the
genie gini the genie coefficient
is a number that
shows the difference the income gap
between rich and poor the higher the
number
the greater the income gap it ranges
from zero to
one so 0.02
to 1.0 so the higher the the higher the
number if you have a gini coefficient of
say
0.7 that's a fairly unequal society
0.7 describes feudal european society
in the middle ages .42 was the roman
empire
most hunter-gatherer societies they have
a genie coefficient of around
0.25 so it much closer to complete
equality than to complete monopoly so
obviously
a society with a hygiene coefficient has
some very powerful wealthy people and a
whole lot of people who aren't doing as
well and that
clearly there's a moral there's a moral
problem there that's not a
good a moral society that's not a good
society
in our terms the problem though is
that the empires
that have dominated world history the
han empire in china the romans
the turks the europeans the empires that
have dominated world history
invariably have high genie coefficients
having a low genie coefficient is a
predictor
of an egalitarian society that actually
does not have a lot of power in the
world and
this one researcher that i talk about in
the book he said that the original one
percent
were these huge huge empires
that controlled enormous percentage of
the world population
in basically a master and servant class
and that those were
those of the empires that in
evolutionary terms they were doing very
very well like
by almost every metric they were
successful societies
they just weren't very just they weren't
very equal
and people in them were not very free
unless you were in the like top
one percent the original what he calls
the original one percent
you cover so much ground in
freedom do you have a particular hope
for what people will
take away from the book or
ponder more closely as a result of
reading the book
is there any any hope kind of tucked
away
or explicit for you that uh that you
hope
will will be achieved by putting this
out into the world
i think with all my work on my books i'm
probably
not alone in this among authors i want
my readers to
understand the human experience in ways
that makes them
more forgiving more compassionate more
insightful and more intolerant
of abuse and violence one reason to
write about
the incredible injustice committed in
the in america
for the civil rights era against african
americans
is that people so people will be
horrified and not tolerate that kind of
thing
for me that's one of the reasons that i
write is to bring
enough understanding to people that they
can act in fair ways
that's true for freedom as well i mean i
want
people to know how valuable how precious
freedom is by seeing the lengths that
people have gone
to maintain it the easter rising in
ireland
against british rule those people made a
lot of a lot of mistakes right i mean it
was you know
they weren't angels but the heroism
the courage the selflessness
i mean there's a passage in my book it's
a letter
written by a irish revolutionary named
michael mallon and he was executed by
the british for his role in the easter
rising and he's
right before he's executed he writes a
letter to his wife and children
it's almost dream of consciousness
because he's so i mean you're about to
shoot him
you know when i read my book i did the
audio recording for my book and in the
studio
you know his letters in my book and i
read it and the director who was sort of
on the
phone with me coveted safe you know
you know advising me directing me in my
reading
i mean we had to stop for a moment
because the letter made her cry is a
hundred years later
the letter made her start crying and you
know he he died for his country
and he had to leave his family his
children right so
what you know i want people to
understand
the incredible dignity and courage
of an awful lot of ver otherwise very
ordinary people
and and that they are they are that way
because they believe in
they believe in human dignity and they
believe that all people
deserve respect and a decent wage
and to live in humane conditions and
you can't i don't think you can read my
book and not not understand those things
a society that's well enough organized
to defend itself is well enough
organized to oppress itself
we need leaders because you know you
can't have an army of
you know you know 100 000 sergeants
right uh or privates you need generals
you need privates you need you know
whatever your society needs to organize
itself and that means that people are in
positions of leadership
and there's an unfortunate tendency for
powerful people in positions of
leadership to exploit
that position and seize rights that
other people don't have
and to enrich themselves in ways that
other people don't have access to
and to be exploitative and abusive and
that is true in dictatorships it's true
in democracies
it's true in every virtually every kind
of society and so i have a i have a
section about leadership and
one of the interesting things about
these small insurgencies like the easter
rising in ireland is that
these marginal groups i mean they're so
outgunned they're so overpowered
by the established political order
military order
that the successful ones
can't afford to have anything
counterproductive in their organization
right they can't have bad leadership
if they do they will get killed right it
will not work and so you can look at
successful even successful start-up
businesses
what are the common elements of these
groups that have overcome enormous odds
and force their vision on the world
hopefully a vision of equality
and dignity and one of the things that
is absolutely essential
is leaders who are willing to die like
leaders who are willing to expose
themselves to the same risks as the
people that they're leading
and when you have leadership that's not
willing to do that
that will not take responsibility for
their mistakes that will blame
problems on others when you have leaders
who are cowards
you have an insurgency that's not going
to last very long and will not succeed
you know wealthy western countries can
afford that kind of leadership because
we're
we are not on the edge of disaster all
the time but you can see what works and
what doesn't by the successful
insurgencies and labor movements and and
what what have you and
and one of the things is moral moral
leadership i do not write about
current day america and i'm not
interested in writing about politics
and i think republicans and democrats
have produced some incredibly inspiring
noble leaders and
and some real villains you know it's
like both sides both
both sides have both the last thing i
would want people to understand from my
book is that we have a right
and in fact i would say we have an
obligation to demand moral leadership
and that means leadership that's
selfless and would sacrifice itself in a
moment
if it meant that that would help the
country and the people who are counting
on them
i'd love to read just a few paragraphs
and to ask follow-up questions
if uh if i may indulge myself here
these are things that jumped out to me
so here's one this is on page 33.
for most of human history freedom had to
be at least suffered for if not died for
and that raised its value to something
almost sacred in modern democracies
however
an ethos of public sacrifice is rarely
needed because freedom and survival are
more or less guaranteed
that is a great blessing but allows
people to believe that any sacrifice at
all
rationing water during a drought for
example are forms of tyranny
there are no more forms of tyranny than
rationing water in a lifeboat
the idea that we can enjoy the benefits
of society while owing nothing in return
is literally infantile
only children owe nothing how do you
think people should
think of what they owe or
how can someone for themselves at least
act as a sort of countervailing force
against
this sort of entitlement and perception
of tyranny and things like rationing
water during a drought
that i think are perverse in a sense but
also very
natural because there is no kind of
imminent threat
that people perceive how do you think
about that or encourage people to think
about that
it's a tricky balance if you're alone in
the wilderness you die humans do not
survive alone
we survive because we're part of a
society
and we get an enormous amount of benefit
from being part of a society and whether
that's at the hunter-gatherer level
or in you know modern america with the
incredible
technological and medical advances you
know i mean among other things i'd be
dead
if i lived in any other society from
what happened to me last june
you know we're enormously blessed and
i think what's essential is to for every
person
to search in their mind for how can we
return the gift the gift of the society
that we live in what can we do to
reinforce
this thing that we depend on for our
survival and
the important thing about to remember
about freedom is that it's
freedom from oppression that you have a
right to
it's not freedom from obligation and we
live in such a wealthy safe society
that real obligation almost never arises
i mean we don't even have the draft
right you got to pay your taxes and
that's it
we have outsourced we have sort of
subcontracted
basically all of the tasks needed for
survival
to specialists to professionals and
that means that what we owe society is
not clear
and there's a real loss there because it
feels good to contribute to the welfare
of the group
you know whether you're on a camping
trip with the boy scouts or as an
american national or an immigrant to
this country for that matter my father
was an immigrant he was a refugee from
two wars and he came to this country and
contributed enormously and was one of
the most
i think meaningful things he did in his
life
was contribute to this country in the
ways that he could
so what can you do as a modern american
where you're not needed
right you can give blood i'm alive
because 10 people gave their blood they
put 10 units in me
i had 10 people's blood inside me and
that's why i survived and then my
daughters will have a father i've never
given blood in my life i'm going to
start
i just never thought about it not only
are you doing something that's good
it reminds you that you're part of this
thing and that you need them and they
need you
and that awareness that back that
exchange between you and them
that's the human experience that's what
life is that's the good stuff
and we live in a wealthy society where
we don't need
the good stuff isn't imposed on us and
we think we're getting away with
something we're actually not we're
actually losing something by not being
part of that
not participating in the common good
jury duty
some people do bad things some people
are accused of doing bad things they
didn't do anything
none of that will get sorted out unless
you're sitting in the jury box
unless you take your turn in that box
it's also i've done it it's also an
incredible experience i mean it really
it's
it's totally fascinating and it doesn't
matter it doesn't have to be a murder
case i mean whatever like it could be
almost anything but it is
this is how society it's society trying
to be fair
and it's a high calling jury duty and
finally of course
vote if you don't vote you are um
you're basically saying i don't care
what happens to me
and i don't care what happens to anybody
else i just don't care about anything
so vote and i haven't voted in every
election in my life either i mean i you
know
like i'm learning as i go and these
these are the things i aspire to it
if we all did them we would have a
spectacular country
we already do but it would be so much
better it would be so much better
protected against
threats that's how you can when you say
enjoy your freedom you can enjoy your
freedom by doing doing those three
things and you actually will enjoy all
of them
it will make you feel like wow i'm a
free person i live in a free society
that's incredible i'm so lucky you know
sebastian i really
admire how expansive the range
is in your writing and so much as you
you can go from the
thirty thousand foot historical multi
millennial view down to
your your day-to-day experience on the
last patrol
and tie it together also the the
incisiveness or incision
i wish i were a writer or something
maybe i'd know which word it is but
yeah of how surgical
you can be with your wording and
observation
i mean this this freedom from oppression
does not equal freedom from obligation
right i mean just just that type of
wordsmithing i wrote it down for myself
is gonna stick
and it's just remarkable how much you're
able to put
without making it impenetrable much the
opposite into
in this case roughly you know 130 135
pages
i want to read one more and this is just
really for enjoyment since
we're talking about a lot of macro level
things we're talking about a lot on the
conceptual level
but one paragraph that's just really a
portion of a
paragraph that i quite enjoyed was the
fire embers
still pulsed and the night air was soft
and benevolent and it felt like summer
waited for us a few days upriver my dog
lay on my ankles and the three other men
shifted and muttered next to me in their
sleep
there may be better things than that but
not many and
hot damn did that make me want to just
get out there on the [ __ ] road
and start walking i gotta say i think
that will probably be a
result of a lot of people reading this
book i have one more
question for you but i think we're
coming to
a close on this conversation is there
anything that you would like to add
any requests of my audience any closing
comments
of any type that you would like to add
before we start to
bring this round to to a close
yeah i mean just just to comment on the
passage you read when we were
out there we needed each other for small
tasks
collecting you know pumping water
cooking dinner making a shelter
finding shelter keeping an eye out for
the cops because we would have been
arrested you know
like i mean whatever any number of
things we got shot at by somebody shot
at us in pennsylvania
one time we walked 40 miles in 40 hours
we were like dead on our feet you know
we went through a lot and we were able
to do it because we could count on each
other
so that feeling at the end of the day
that you just read
that came i was there with my brothers
and my dog and that feeling of
contentedness
came from the fact that i knew i could
count on those guys
and they knew they could count on me and
we had all needed all of us
to be okay and it's easier to do that
it's more obvious it's clearer doing
that in a small group
but the end of the day 330 million
people
are trying to do that in a country and
we all have to think that way if
amer america doesn't have to survive it
could die
it could split up it could fragment it
could implode
there's no rule there's nothing written
down saying this has to work
it's going to work if we
make it work and that means thinking
about
people in this country the way me and
the other guys thought of each other
on that trip it's a hard thing to do for
330 million people
it's never been tried in history before
right but that doesn't mean it can't be
done
and i think each political you know
there's a difficult political moment
right now let's just say it it's
obvious each side has to stop accusing
the other side for a moment and look at
it at its own flaws
the idea that's popular in the right
wing that you don't have to wear a mask
to protect your fellow americans from
disease it's just silly
it's just ridiculous and juvenile on the
other side
on the left i grew up in a democratic
family
a liberal area got lots of left wing
friends
if i suggest that national service
mandatory national
service might be a good idea for this
country not necessarily the military
you know but there's a lot of ways to
serve your country you know other than
with a gun
that national service might be a good
idea the people that flame me they're
not right-wing people they're left-wing
people
they think they don't know anything we
all owe something and it's all of our
duty as americans and as human beings to
figure out
what we owe and what the most is that we
can give
and i'll tell you what not only might
that save the country it'll save you
here here well sebastian i did say i had
one more question
and this is gonna veer back into
self-indulgent therapy
session again i'm thinking well not i
my partner and i my wonderful girlfriend
and i are
thinking about kids in the very near
future
and i can't help but have this
nagging voice in the back of my head
saying you're not ready
you don't know what you're doing how
could you possibly know what you're
doing so there is some
fear there for me since we last spoke
you have two new members of your family
any advice any thoughts to a a would-be
but fearful new parent possible parent
well first of all brother do it
i mean seriously like just just do it
and i'm thrilled for you and it's just
the best thing
there is you know maybe it's not the
best thing at 20 but
eventually it's the best thing there is
and you're not supposed to know how to
do it you haven't done it yet
but humans are adaptive and they're
smart you know like you'll figure it out
i mean it's not we're animals animals
know how to take care of their young
instinctively they do you know and
there's a website called evolutionary
parenting
which looks at parenting from an
evolutionary perspective and tries to
put it into the context of modern
society
super helpful but you know also i was
talking about this with my wife
kids are you know sometimes they're just
a freak show right i mean some of the
emotions like
like they don't cover their emotions
very well so stuff comes out that's just
you know the tantrums and this and that
and you you know we're problem solvers
right so i'm like
how can i fix this my daughter's crying
she's she's throwing stuff you know like
what can i
i gotta fix this you don't have to fix
it nothing lasts very long
you just have to give them a safe wise
compassionate
environment until whatever feeling that
is passes
and i guarantee you certainly within an
hour but probably within a few minutes
it's over
so you ride it out man and you ride it
out with with love basically
and some instructive discipline when
needed you know but you'll know
you'll know what's right well sebastian
it's so
enjoyable for me to spend time with you
it's so nice to
reconnect it really doesn't feel that
long ago
that i was watching you type if i
remember correctly
hunting and pecking with two fingers and
i asked you
do you write all the time like that and
you're like yep
has that changed or is that still the
same no no i don't know i don't i mean
if you hit age 59 and you're still
typing with two fingers
you're probably gonna die that way
and i'm so happy for you you really
sound good
and i am thrilled
that you've put this small and powerful
tome out into the world freedom i highly
suggest people pick it up
i just am consistently and i've already
said this but i'll say it again just
consistently
so impressed and i say this is someone
who who could probably use 10 more
editors on every one of my books because
they're phone books for god's sake
how much you are able to pack
into very slim
books without at least in my mind
without sacrificing
the essence or the details i really just
don't know how you do it it's
tremendously impressive to me so i i do
impress upon
people both the quality of the writing
but more so than that it's not just
wordsmithing it's it's really the
power of the storytelling and the
concepts and the history that you weave
together
so people should check out freedom they
can find you online sebastian
younger.com sebastianjunger on
twitter facebook and then instagram
sebastianyoungerofficial
and thank you once again for for taking
the time i hope to break some bread
in person at some point soon once we get
uh
get to the the light at the end of the
tunnel here with
with vaccination and so forth thank you
very much it was a real pleasure and
and good luck with your next next
adventure i hope it works and and i look
forward to hearing it
yeah the next adventure if not for any
other reason that i'm
thoroughly exhausted by thinking about
myself and would like to shift that
focus
so be nice nice to shift that lens
and to everybody listening for show
notes on everything we've discussed
links to everything we discussed
including freedom we will put those show
notes at tim.log forward slash podcast
and it will all be easy to find and
until next time just remember
among many things freedom from
oppression does not
equal freedom from obligation donate
blood
see what you can contribute back society
does give
every one of us each and every one of us
a whole lot
and until next time thanks for listening
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every
friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's four
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
aura o-u-r-a it is the only wearable
that i wear on a daily
basis aura is the company behind the
smart ring that delivers personalized
sleep and health insights to help you
optimize
just about everything and i've tried
every device out there that you can
imagine
this one really makes the cut i've been
using it religiously for at least six
months now
and i was introduced to it by dr peter
etia who's also vetted
just about everything with advanced
sensors orapack's state-of-the-art heart
rate heart rate variability hrv
super important to me temperature
activity and sleep monitoring technology
into a convenient
non-invasive ring it's tiny it weighs
less than six grams and focuses on
three key insights sleep readiness and
activity so
i can use it to help focus my attention
on the type
volume intensity of exercise that i
should do in a given day
i use it to determine how certain types
of alcohol at different times of the day
affect
my sleep which they do and i can see all
of that in graph form trended over time
there are tons of actionable insights
that have come from using this ring
for me they have a number of incredible
people on
their team dr matthew walker a professor
of neuroscience and psychology at uc
berkeley
and also author of why we sleep the
mega hit is aura's chief science advisor
as just one example
the aura ring is one of the most
accurate wearables available because it
measures your vitals directly from your
finger so it's
not deducing that or
making a best guesstimate based on a
bunch of other things and trying to
triangulate
compared to a medical grade
electrocardiogram the aura ring is
99.9 accurate for resting heart rate
and 98.4 accurate for heart rate
variability and i work with hrv doctors
and they recommend
that i use the aura ring so try it
yourself it is
super cool and super practical very
actionable
the aura ring comes in two styles and
three colors
silver black and matte black i use matte
black
for 299 dollars you can give or
get the gift of health by visiting
auraring.com
that's o u r a r i n g
dot com again that's aura ring dot com
this episode is brought to you by mac
weldon
magwelden is reinventing men's basics
they believe in smart design premium
fabrics and
simple shopping i've been smashing and
testing
the hell out of a bunch of their stuff
and i'm gonna focus on their underwear
as one example
i've been wearing their air knit x five
inch boxer briefs
for a while now and i absolutely love
them i've used them to hike
in national parks like big bend i use
them to record podcasts
they can be used for anything they're
engineered to keep you dry cool and
comfortable
to the end of your workout or work day
the fabric is soft
lightweight microfiber which maximizes
airflow and stretches in every direction
it's breathable
moisture wicking and odor fighting which
is great for a bridge troll
like me here's what a few critics have
to say new york times
wire cutter evaluated mack weldon's 18
hour jersey
boxer brief here we go quote our testers
seemed almost conflicted about how fancy
they felt while wearing these boxer
briefs
quote these are lovely you put them on
and you feel rich one tester
said this underwear makes me want to
waste money on a hotel room and fancy
boost to seduce my already wife and
spoil her right
added another now to esquire quote an
expertly executed pair of briefs from a
brand that doesn't better than almost
anyone else and quote now to men's
health but mack weldon took the process
seriously
with over 10 000 hours to perfect the
best underwear
money can buy seriously this one checks
all the boxes you should be looking for
when purchasing underwear end quote
now back to me mac walden also covers a
lot more than underwear
they have socks shirts underwear hoodies
polos active shorts
they check all the boxes macweld then
promises comfort and a consistent fit
for all of your basics
so check them out and try them out if
you don't like your first pair of
underwear you can actually keep them and
they will still
refund you no questions asked so you
have nothing to lose
again my favorite so far is probably the
air knit x
five inch boxer briefs it seems like the
18 hour
jersey boxer brief is one of the most
popular so check them out
to get 20 percent off of your first
order visit macweldon.com
timtim and enter promo code timtim
that's
m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n-dot-com
tim and use promo code tim tim mack
weldon
reinventing men's basics
you